i love my brother but ted kaczynski's
brother loved him too
oh what you thought that witnesses just
showed up at trial having
never practiced their testimony before
oh you sweet
sweet summer child
so i have a confession to make this is
not the first time i've seen this
episode of better call saul called
chicanery it's the episode that involves
a bar disciplinary trial and
i saw this episode about a year ago and
ever since then i haven't been able to
think about
anything else if you've seen it you know
that there are questions about whether
what jimmy did is legal and not only
whether it's legal but also
whether the things that he does would
actually work in this bar disciplinary
hearing and whether the evidence that he
generates would be admissible
in court i think i finally know how
everything connects
and whether it's accurate or not so
let's dig in to better call saul
chicanery charles thinks that jimmy
somehow took control of your documents
while he was working on them at his home
he believes
jimmy transposed the address numbers
transpose the numbers
how would he even do that charles
contends that
jimmy took the documents pertaining to
the rosella branch and while charles was
indisposed
photocopied and doctor them that's
pretty baroque okay so this is the
background to the episode
and it is true that under the rules of
professional conduct if a lawyer
realizes that a document has been
fabricated they have an obligation to
tell the tribunal or the court that it
has been
doctored and come forward with that now
it's also just good client management
kim is trying to do the right thing here
this is a pr issue for the client
and it might reflect poorly on the
client itself
okay this is it we can run without
lights
and mics we'll collect all cell phones
and hold them for the duration of your
testimony
okay so a reminder here this is not a
normal trial this is a disciplinary
hearing by the bar
so it's a question of whether jimmy gets
to keep his uh bar license and of course
his brother
chuck claims to be allergic to
electricity so they're
turning off all the lights to
accommodate him this is probably going
to be more like an arbitration
less formal but still has the force of
law here but look i'm making assumptions
here i don't know exactly what the state
bar of new mexico would be doing under
these circumstances
how you feeling chuck i'll muddle
through
because this is a lot to ask and if
you're not up to it just throwing this
out there
maybe you don't need to testify at all
no i do i'm the only person who can
adequately explain the context of that
tape otherwise the defense will tear it
to shreds
it's already a solid case we have
jimmy's statement from the
pre-prosecution diversion there's my
testimony and the private eyes
maybe there's no need to put you through
the ringer like this
okay so a couple of things here number
one the tape here
is that chuck recorded jimmy basically
confessing to the
crimes that issue here of doctoring the
the evidence so it shows one of the
reasons why jimmy should be disbarred
but another thing's going on here is
something that does actually happen
which is that you can
often guild the lily in trial some
witnesses are going to be better than
others and if you already have
a rock solid case and you have a witness
who doesn't play well on the stand or
there are other issues that are going to
confuse the jury or the judge
then it's best not to put that witness
forward because it's just going to
detract from your already strong case
and of course
chuck isn't listening to that and i
don't think his law partner can stop him
here
but we know that this is also
foreshadowing that
uh he is not the best witness to tell
the story and bad things are going to
happen
because he refuses to not take the stand
in the matter of james m mcgill the
state bar intends to prove the following
violations of the ethical code
16-102 engaging in conduct the lawyer
knows is criminal
mr mcgill certainly knew that breaking
down his brother's door was criminal
behavior
16-804 committing a criminal act
that reflects adversely on the lawyer's
honesty or trustworthiness as a lawyer
any reasonable person would agree that
assaulting another lawyer in his own
home
reflects badly on mr mcgill's fitness as
an attorney
i think those are the actual rules of
professional conduct
i i think that is also the case in new
mexico certainly the
section numbers correspond with the aba
model professional codes not
surprisingly lawyers cannot engage in
manifestly illegal conduct and they
can't engage in conduct that
reflects on the honesty of themselves
and the profession so i think those are
the actual things that jimmy would be
charged with in exactly this
circumstance
that's great attention to detail right
there mr mcgill broke into his brother's
home
and destroyed an audio cassette which
contained a recording of a conversation
between himself and his brother charles
mcgill
we will show that this recording was
evidence in an ongoing legal case
the state bar believes that once we have
presented the facts
the committee will agree that disbarment
is warranted for james mcgill
thank you very much okay so assuming
that this is
an opening statement in a trial and yeah
they're gonna be differences given that
this is a bar disciplinary hearing
i would have liked to have heard more
about the facts that the state or the
state bar is going to prove here they
focused on the law
here that is relevant and that law
appears to be spot on and
that probably makes sense in a
disciplinary hearing but at the same
time he is using the language of an
opening statement that they are going to
prove
these things that we're not arguing
anything here we're just giving an
opening statement about
what the facts and the law are going to
be and
that's that's pretty accurate i'm kim
wexler co-counsel with james mcgill
for the defense you've already read mr
mcgill's pre-prosecution statement
we don't dispute he broke into his
brother's house an act he regrets
deeply but there is another side to this
story
one not about calculation or
ill intent but about two brothers
whose relationship after years of strain
finally broke we believe that after you
have the complete picture
you'll understand james mcgill is an
asset to our legal community
and he should remain a full member of it
in good standing
okay another super short very surgical
opening statement from kim here
again i would have liked her to focus on
more of the facts they've
opened the question about the
relationship between the two brothers
and how that colors this whole thing
how could this crime be turned from
something that's clearly illegal into
something that is
understandable and forgivable because of
the brothers relationship frankly if
jimmy is
on the stand he can lay a lot of that
foundation mr alley call your witness
bang bang bang then he kicked down the
door
jimmy was very agitated he was shouting
he demanded
charles turn over the evidence he'd been
objection we haven't established the
tape
is evidence of anything the defense has
only acknowledged it as a piece of
property
uh allow me to rephrase i love that
hamlin
is actually adding some drama because he
is a
seasoned trial lawyer so he does know
what works and what doesn't work
on the stand this objection that kim has
made basically the judge will smack that
down and say look
i understand that this is the witness's
opinion and i'll take it for what it's
worth and so they're not going to
strike the testimony here they're just
going to say be careful try not to
editorialize or opine from the stand and
that's exactly what the
witness then does when you make an
objection like this if you're really
worried about the particular testimony
you have to ask the judge or
in this case the the panel to strike
that testimony from the record otherwise
it stays there and
everyone is allowed to rely on that
testimony so anytime you see
an objection if they're not getting rid
of the testimony that shouldn't have
come out in the first place
it was a completely ineffectual act
jimmy demanded an audio cassette
in charles's possession which jimmy
proceeded with the help of an iron
fireplace implement
to pry from charles's desk he then broke
the cassette into pieces and went on to
confront his brother
what happened after the defendant
smashed this tape
it's a great direct examination question
in on direct you're not allowed to ask
leading questions you are on cross and
what happened next is perfect you're
just teeing it up for the witness to
explain away
everything that the witness can say and
when you have a great witness like
hamlin here
just let them do the talking what was
your opinion of him then
i thought he had a lot of get up and go
he was a hard worker you had a nickname
for him didn't you
charlie hustle so interesting easter egg
here this is an illegal thing but that
is the nickname
for pete rose who was banned from
baseball for betting on games that he
was
a player in and a manager of it's an
interesting nickname to give
uh jimmy there could you speak to the
terms of charles's leave of absence
you know i can't it was an fmla leave
anything more is confidential okay uh
spot on the fmla
is the family and medical leave act that
allows people to take medical leave
and the employer under most
circumstances is required to allow them
to come back to their job there are some
exceptions
if that job has been completely removed
for example then there's no obligation
to bring them back to that job but that
is exactly what would happen
in a situation like this and the
employer's under an obligation
not to disclose the reason for the
employee taking the
leave at this time the state bar would
like to enter exhibit five
into evidence we ask that charles
mcgill's recording be played
i'm respectfully renewing my objection
the probate value of playing this
exhibit is outweighed by how prejudicial
it is all due respect to miss wechsler
but the state bar feels this is
fundamental to hear
we don't want to leave any question as
to the intentions of both parties
ms wexler we already ruled this was fair
game when we denied your motion to
suppress
i'll add the roughing tumble of your
client's conduct aside
we need to know whether one lawyer
attempted to tamper with another's
evidence
okay this is great for a couple of
reasons number one the objection that
kim is making
is a real objection under the rules of
evidence if a piece of evidence
has a prejudicial value that outweighs
its probate value in other words
how relevant it is to the proceedings
then under certain circumstances the
judge or the tribunal can rule that it's
inadmissible because it's just say too
inflammatory or too prejudicial but
what's great about this
and what you rarely ever see on tv is
that
these issues of very very important
pieces of evidence
are almost never dealt with in the trial
itself there's almost always pre-trial
briefing and here
there was pre-trial briefing they moved
to suppress it that motion was denied
and so effectively they already dealt
with this issue and almost always on tv
there's this back and forth between
these objections and
sometimes heard in the presence of the
jury in reality in real life
it's done in a very dry way you file a
motion to either admit the evidence or
to prevent it from coming in the judge
rules on it ahead of time and you save
everyone the heartache of going back and
forth
on the day of the trial it's amazing you
never see that on tv
i love my brother but ted kaczynski's
brother loved him too
oh what you thought that witnesses just
showed up at trial having
never practiced their testimony before
oh you sweet
sweet summer child kim deserves mesa
verde not you
not hhm she earned it and she needs it
i did it to help her but i i honestly
didn't think it would hurt you so bad i
thought you'd just say
oh crap i made a mistake and go on with
your life like a normal person but oh no
wishful thinking all right so obviously
this raises
huge ethical implications for kim
representing jimmy here i'm gonna assume
that representing someone in a bar
disciplinary hearing is basically an act
of a lawyer
and they're bound by the same ethical
issues and she's a material witness here
she
is one of the reasons that this whole
situation has come to fruition
it's a little crazy for her to be
counsel here despite the fact that she's
a law partner with jimmy
and maybe especially because they're law
partners it's pretty improper
for her to be counsel for jimmy in this
particular situation
jimin you do realize you just confessed
to a felony yes
but you feel better right besides it's
your word against mine
so yeah look tampering with evidence to
try and obstruct an investigation or to
interfere with another court case
clearly
clearly illegal and new mexico is a
one-party consent
state so it's probably okay for chuck to
have
uh recorded this conversation in which
he is participating bad evidence for
jimmy
excuse me sorry
hule everyone loves fuel heal is the
best uh so we know that he has
bumped into charles he has of course
planted something on charles's person
that will become
relevant later on this is also
incredibly relevant for
the crazy legal analysis that i had to
do to figure out what's going on here
because
number one he's made physical contact
with charles
which raises the issue of whether that
is its own
crime of assault and or battery and
whether planting something
on chuck's person can be admissible
evidence we'll get to that in a second
but those are the kinds
of legal issues that we have to think
about here and it's gonna spiral out of
control really fast
i had a suspicion my brother had
tampered with documents in the case i
was working on
now why would he do that doesn't sound
particularly brotherly
i believe it was his hope that the
tainted documents would cause the client
to become
disillusioned with my representation and
return to their previous attorney
object object yeah you're not gonna be
allowed to speculate as to
the kind of motive uh or internal
thinking that the jimmy's going on here
which i should note is precisely what
happened
objection finally saying ms wexler knew
what jimmy was doing or had any
involvement
i'm only stating that it happened but
the witness can't keep testifying
if you're objecting to the the court
here this happens a lot in tv
if there's an objection the witness has
to stop and if you win that objection
you need to go back and say that you
move that the testimony be stricken from
the record otherwise it's on the record
and it happened
my brother whatever else can be said of
him can be quite clever
did an excellent job of covering his
tracks objection
the witness has admitted there's no
corroborating evidence this supposed
crime even occurred
i'd like to hear what he has to say okay
this is called the speaking objection
and the problem with that is that while
some of the rationale that she's using
makes sense she's also not giving them a
reason under the rules of evidence why
they cannot hear this evidence and the
reason is it's pure speculation he has
admitted that he doesn't have
corroborating evidence you're not
allowed to testify to that and
the judge shouldn't be saying i want to
hear what he says now again
this is something that's like a bench
trial something that's like an
arbitration
you see it all the time they say look
i'll hear the testimony i understand
that he might be purely speculating but
i want to hear that speculation it might
be based on something
and i am smart enough to know whether i
can trust that testimony
or not you see that a lot in
arbitrations or bench trials
all due respect but but you do sound
somewhat unhinged on the recording
yes i understand that but what you heard
was theater
a performance play play-acting i
exaggerated the
symptoms of my disease to extract the
truth
i don't think that that's relevant here
they are kind of opening the door to
jimmy and kim
here to probe the veracity of it that's
that's a dangerous gamble
can we talk about your disease for a
moment i'd like everybody here to be on
the same page about it
of course it is sometimes referred to as
ehs
electromagnetic hypersensitivity i
describe it as an acute allergy to
electromagnetism not a common condition
is it
i know it sounds strange i do but 30
years ago no one had heard of peanut
allergies
okay so this is really important because
generally in the law there is this idea
that you take your victim as you find
them
and often this is lumped in with the
eggshell skull theory where let's say
you
punch someone and they happen to suffer
from
a bone disease that gives them brittle
bones or
a skull that is so thin is to be like an
eggshell well
the mere fact that you didn't intend for
some horrific injury to come as a result
of a mere punch given the special
circumstances of the victim
it doesn't matter you take your victim
as you find them and that's really
relevant to the some things that we're
gonna get to because
chuck believes he has this disease and
in some sense that
matters whether that disease is true or
not in other senses it matters only
whether chuck
believes he has this disease or not and
his subjective reaction to it
that'll become relevant in just a second
i love my brother
there's nothing malicious in jimmy
he has a way of doing the worst things
for reasons that sound almost noble
but what i know for sure is that the law
is too important to be toyed with
it's mankind's greatest achievement the
rule of law the idea that no matter who
you are
your actions have consequences preach
baby preach
i have some questions like the recorder
it must have hurt like hell for you to
touch that
there was a degree of discomfort that's
true and where did you hide it
i mean the sound's pretty clear so it
wasn't in the couch cushions was it
tucked under a space blanket out of
sight wow
so there's no chance i would see it not
with the state your place was in isn't
that right
i suppose would you like to set the
scene for the disciplinary committee
tell them
you know what your house looked like at
the time of the recording so jimmy's
asking a combination of open-ended and
leading questions and i remind you that
on cross-examination
you are allowed to ask leading questions
it's only on direct examination where
you're not allowed to ask
leading questions i covered most of the
walls with foil scrim craft insulation
i also hung a number of space blankets
compact mylar sheets
they insulate and protect against mild
electromagnetic radiation
all right so shiny insulation and space
blankets all over the walls and the
ceiling
it was like being inside of a disco ball
do you have a point
okay now jimmy is just flat-out
testifying he turns to the tribe you
know and he just starts
saying what his own experience is like
you can't do that on cross-examination
he's a witness here
if he wants to take the stand and
testify as to what he saw and
experienced
he's gonna be able to do that usually
it's a perfectly normal house
you think your house is normal can i
call your attention to exhibit nine
this is your house right yes
it's exposed wires
there's a camp stove
okay so putting aside the fact that
jimmy is basically testifying right
now i find this hilarious because every
trial
has these exhibit binders and again
you're gonna take care of most of the
evidentiary stuff ahead of time so it's
pretty normal for all of the exhibits to
already be
in evidence and we tend to carry these
boxes of white three ring binders or
black three ring binders
containing everything if he'd planned
this out he probably would have blown up
these pictures on
like a three by five presentation board
but spur the moment he
wants to confront the witness with these
trial exhibits
totally spot on hilarious the attention
to detail here and on top of that yes
he's sort of testifying but
he would be able to make the exact same
points by simply saying
is this your house do you recognize this
as a true and correct picture of what
was in your house
and is it true as depicted in this photo
that there was exposed wire is it true
that blah blah
you just simply confront the witness to
verify all of these things so you get
the same effect of being able to show
the tribunal all of these
these photos so yeah he's testifying
here but in reality what he would
realistically do with this witness is
not that far off it's great
right so with the lights out you don't
feel them if the current's not flowing
no
oh sorry about the exit signs i guess
they couldn't kill those for you
well they're not drawing much current
and they're far away
the intensity drops off with distance
per the inverse square law
okay whoa inverse square i'm not a
physicist could you dumb that down a
shade for me
the farther away it is the stronger the
source needs to be to have an effect
all right huel is back that'll become
relevant in just a second now things are
about to get good oh my god i think i
figured it out
i can't wait to untangle this web again
i might have seen this before got it got
it so if i had a small battery safe
from a watch or something and i got it
close to you close to your skin you'd
know
i would feel it yes okay laying the
foundation that a battery
is something that he would feel and he
would react to can you feel more current
coming from any particular direction
right now
from the back wall or uh from over there
or
up through the floor can you tell us
where the nearest source is
right now
jimmy do you have something in your
pocket no he laid the trap he laid the
trap
yes i do as a matter of fact
my cell phone from this distance you
should feel it
and you don't do you mr mcgill you were
warned to leave your electronics outside
it's a trap it's a trap so starting out
here
i don't think that there's any issue
with him using his cell phone as a prop
you use demonstratives in trial all the
time you know you can
generate testimony through the witness
on the stand and the fact that it's his
own
cell phone it's unorthodox sure but so
is this medical ailment and
in reality you can get a medical
examination
uh through discovery if this was an
actual court case so i think
so far so good this is akin to in my
cousin vinnie when
joe pesci is holding up two fingers to
test the
eyesight of a witness how many fingers
am i holding up now
full i i don't think there's anything
untoward going on so far
what do i have to do to prove it to you
i don't know chuck
could you reach into your breast pocket
and tell me what's there
what now
can you tell the court what that was
it's a battery
it was on him the whole time we
recognize that man in back
his name is huel babano he's on our
witness list you bumped into him in the
stairway
he'll testify he planted this fully
charged battery on you
over an hour and a half ago hour and 43
minutes
an hour and 43 minutes thank you mr
babano
and you felt nothing here's where things
get
really really dicey where do i start i'm
just i'm just so excited there's so much
stuff going on here first of all uh the
issue of
jimmy testifying okay yeah all right so
jimmy is sort of testifying here but i
think what you would assume would happen
is that the state would object and what
jimmy's actually doing is he isn't
testifying so much as
he's making a proffer he actually says
this is hule babineau
uh he will testify or he says something
perspective in there
he's saying i'm not offering this into
evidence right now but in the future
this person will testify to this and
here's why it's relevant lawyers do
proffers all the time
often in response to an objection of
relevance so yes he is technically
testifying himself but he's only
testifying into the things that this
witness huel babano will testify to
in the future and i'm sure if this
disciplinary hearing goes forward
he will make hubebino take the stand and
testify to all the things that have
happened right now so it's conflating a
couple of things together
but it's not that crazy it's a proffer
but now is the secondary issue of
did jimmy commit a crime to elicit this
testimony
i think there's an argument that he did
because there is the crime of
battery which is also a torque where you
engage in some sort
of harmful or offensive contact to
another person now harmful or offensive
doesn't just mean like punching someone
or stabbing them with a with a knife but
it also includes things that are
singularly offensive only to the victim
themselves contact that's highly
offensive
to another's unusually sensitive sense
and the actor knows that that contact is
highly offensive to them
so when you're dealing with someone that
is incredibly unique
the assailant has to know that it's
highly offensive to them arguably
that's the case here jimmy knows that
chuck feels this way regardless of
whether
it's true or not that he actually
suffers from this condition so
in the restatement of torts for example
they give a couple of examples of things
like this
serving pork to someone who doesn't eat
pork for religious reasons
it's not going to hurt them but it might
be highly offensive to them or they give
another example of
someone who is deathly afraid of
butterflies well the butterfly's not
going to hurt them but if you put a
butterfly on someone
and they freak out well you've just
committed battery if you know that they
are terrified
of butterflies and it generally doesn't
matter if the victim didn't know about
it ahead of time the
damage is done when they find out about
it the person who ate pork
didn't know that they ate pork but if
you tell them about it well then they
have suffered
the emotional distress of the battery
even if it's after the fact
on the other hand there is an argument
that this melody is not a real thing
and therefore he didn't suffer anything
and a reasonable person wouldn't suffer
that either i don't know i could go
either way on this
and as for whether it's admissible in
front of this tribunal remember this is
more informal than a normal court but
man
this one is still a tough one because we
don't want
defense attorneys accosting a material
witness and
planting things on them for what is
obviously
highly probative evidence such a great
scene
i absolutely still love it regardless of
whether it would work or not
it's just it's just really good you
think this is bad
this this chicanery he's done worse
that's billboard are you telling me that
a man just happens to fall like that
no he orchestrated it jimmy
he defecated through a sunroof
uh who doesn't love a great perry mason
moment this episode is just
so good
[Music]
so now i have to give this episode of
better call saul a grade for legal
realism
on the one hand they're taking some
liberties here we've got people
testifying you have people
engaging in things that normally
wouldn't be allowed in trial but on the
other hand this is a disciplinary
hearing things are going to be more
informal and they really paid very close
attention to
the actual ethical rules for lawyers and
things like fmla
and they were making reasonably good
objections even though this caused me to
pull my hair out for
months i think this is one of the
greatest episodes of tv lawyering of all
time and i'm gonna give it an a minus
just don't engage this kind of chicanery
as a real lawyer
now this video isn't over i had to cut
this down almost in half because i had
so many things to say
like i said i really loved this episode
but lucky for you you can watch the full
extended version over on nebula which
you can now get with a huge discount
when you get it with curiosity stream
because
sometimes having a 50-minute reaction
video to a 45-minute tv show
doesn't actually work on youtube which
is why my creator friends and i teamed
up to build our own platform where
creators don't need to worry about
demonetization or the dreaded algorithm
as you know this platform is called
nebula and we're partnering with
curiosity stream and not only are the
nebula versions ad-free and extended but
they also get released early before the
youtube versions because
nebula is a place where we can
experiment with content and put things
out that we couldn't put on youtube
and it features lots of youtube's top
educational-ish creators like
mkbhd lindsey ellis and philosophytube
and we're thrilled to be partnering with
curiosity stream because they're the
go-to source for the best documentaries
and long-form educational content on the
internet
and now they have an entire section
devoted to unsolved mysteries and crime
if you like my videos you will love the
stuff on curiositystream
and we worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiosity stream with the
link in the description
you also get a nebula subscription for
free and to be clear that nebulous
subscription is not a trial
it's free for as long as you're a
curiosity stream member and right now
curiosity stream is
offering 26 off of their annual plans
that's
less than 15 per year for both curiosity
stream and nebula so if you click on the
link in the description you'll get both
curiosity stream and nebula for 26
off or you can go to curiositystream.com
legaleagle
it's a great way to support this channel
and educational content directly
for less than 15 for the entire year
so just click on the link in the
description plus clicking that link
really helps out this channel so do you
agree with my analysis leave your
objections
in the comments and tell me what tv show
i should do next
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other real law reviews
including
the simpsons it's always sunny in
philadelphia and my cousin vinnie so
click on this playlist or i'll see you
in court